[Music]
Welcome to My Garage this is my brain
this is where I have to make the magic
happen
Laura cable is a Disney imagineer
for the last five years many of them
surrounded by Blueprints and scale
models from her garage here in Los
Angeles thanks to the pandemic she's
been running the Creative Design of a
cruise ship nearly as long as the Eiffel
Tower the Disney wish
thank you
the scale of it is unbelievable you know
they're 1.2 million square feet at least
they're more than three football fields
long but a Disney cruise ship there's no
other cruise ship like it
[Music]
I'm Chad Cohen a filmmaker at National
Geographic and you're listening to
overheard a show where we eavesdrop on
the wild conversations we have here at
Nat Geo and follow them to the edges of
our big weird beautiful world
this week I'm here at Disneyland to talk
with Laura cable about the Disney wish
we discuss what it means to be an
imagineer and how she turned her vision
for the Disney wish into reality
the Walt Disney Company is majority
owner of National Geographic media I
worked with Laura and her team to
produce a documentary on the making of
the wish coming soon to Disney plus and
for over a year I got to follow her from
her tiny little Garage in California to
the enormous Shipyard in Germany where
Parts arrived from all over the world to
assemble into what is basically a
floating Disney Castle
she'll tell you how it happened right
after the break
fuel your curiosity with a free
one-month trial subscription to Nat
geodigital you'll have unlimited access
on any device anywhere ad-free with our
app that lets you download stories to
read offline explore every page ever
published with a Sentry of digital
archives at your fingertips check it all
out for free at nachio.com Explore More
thank you
Lara leads the creative development for
the current Fleet of Disney cruise ships
but she got her start as an architect
dreaming Up structures meant for Solid
Ground among her many architectural
Feats she helped design the Cleveland
Botanical Gardens and Ohio's glass house
before designing hotels and other
buildings for Walt Disney imagineering
what's an imagineer Walt Disney
imagineer it's 146 plus disciplines
right Engineers Architects interior
designers aerospace engineers
show production designers music I mean
You Name It We Do It
we are the creative arm of the Walt
Disney Company so we design everything
within the parks the resorts and our
cruise ships
was the wish your first cruise ship then
yeah
so what was that like it was hard to
imagine when you kept walking around
this big steel vessel that still didn't
have a lot of finishes on it
how long does it take to finish how does
it finish when do we have time to go in
there and do all of our show production
and planning
unlike a land project you can't make
changes in quite the same way right I
mean things are and you can and I know
you did but things are things are pretty
well boxed and you need to make these
decisions a long time ago right and then
you have to live you have to live with
that because you're not going to easily
change steel you know you're not gonna
create a two-story space somewhere else
so for me someone from outside with the
job of bringing to life what you're
bringing to life you've got you know
this thing this it's not a boat it's a
ship we have to be very clear that was
totally very early on a boat never a
boat
um and you know it's it's 144 000
um gross tons it's it's nearly as long
as the Eiffel Tower three football
fields like all the big crazy Dimensions
so on that grand scale you're designing
but then it's also these tiny tiny tiny
details that maybe the guests will
notice maybe they will well someone will
at some point and I think that's the
thing about imagineering and about
Disney is that
there is so much thought put into
everything that even if the guest
doesn't
outright notice everything it's all
leading to this huge emotional thing
that they feel
all right so to someone who doesn't know
anything about cruise ships
how would you describe a cruise ship oh
my gosh okay I was someone who knew
nothing about cruise ships five years
ago so how would I describe that I was
stunned when I walked into a shipyard
hall for the first time and it just
struck me like I'm standing in front of
the pyramids it's huge it's just
inconceivable how
people can build this and put something
so gigantic together and then how does
the weight of it not plunge through the
concrete floor of the dry dock I don't
understand that it should just dissolve
yeah let alone float on the surface of
the ocean right right so when it comes
to a ship
and designing the spaces the interior
and I guess somewhat exterior space of
the ship you've got steel you've got you
know restrictions for for I would
imagine height and weight and all these
things like how much flexibility is
there and how you know how do you kind
of push that yeah so I I like to think
of it as there are a lot of restrictions
you know in terms of all of the things
you specified the ship is moving so you
have to be really careful with how you
design things you know chandeliers and
and things that might move on the ship
you can't have that and then there's a
whole host of materials anything you
might use in the Interiors has to meet
very strict International Marine
organization standards so in some
regards it is challenging but in other
regards from a Disney storytelling point
of view
it's sort of boundless
but it's a very different thing to build
a ship yeah I mean one of our first
things that we shot for the film we went
over to Germany and we found out the
bridge was being installed even the
giant blocks of the ship it's built Lego
style they will lower that thing into
place and they're measuring millimeters
it's unbelievable how they can do that
like we were there together when the the
Giga block as we call it the midship
right it floated in from another part of
the world that's the other thing is they
build the they build the ships in Parts
in many different places and then at
some point they sail the sort of section
of the ship it's sort of crazy it is and
they sail that over and then they put it
into the hall and then they marry it to
the fourship and then the astounding
thing to me is they just there's like a
seam right that runs around the whole
entire ship where the four ship joins
with the midship and the midship to the
AFT and that's a weld just a weld but
the weld is apparently the strongest
thing in the world yeah that's what they
told us these ships together yeah it's
amazing it really is
after the break we'll hear more from
Laura cable she'll tell us what it takes
to become an imagineer and the last
moments of finishing the inside of the
ship while it sailed from Germany to the
site of its first maiden voyage in Port
Canaveral Florida
foreign
so why don't we talk about the grand
hall so that one
is kind of important because it's where
you enter the ship right and set the
tone right sets the tone for your entire
um Cruise so you know we we want to
ensure when the guest walks in there
that they're just in awe you know they
should walk in and think oh my gosh how
can a space like this be on a ship
I think what was interesting to me is
that it's a
it's a choice that you have to make like
on a ship more than anywhere else it's
not like you can expand into something
else and having a big wide open space
um in a in a steel structure that floats
it was a challenge it's a challenge to
go three decks high for that or more is
it more it's three yes so so you know
that's something that in a big wide open
space it's not something that's that's
easy to do it costs oh yeah absolutely
yes and then we have to be very careful
with weight distribution across the ship
so just as we're
you know sort of being boundless with
our imagination we also have all of
these critical things that we have to
meet and check off and so it's a balance
of technical as well as you know
creativity
um and you know the other complexity is
the logistics you know
um ensuring that we're going to get
materials that need to come from China
or maybe you know the stern character in
itself was stun character yeah Rapunzel
was created in the desert in California
I'm sorry I interrupted tell me what
what's the stern character okay so the
stern character is unique to Disney we
have a Stern character which is a giant
statue that's attached to the the back
of the ship the stern of the ship so in
the case of the wish that is Rapunzel
and I believe she has like over 50 feet
of hair that just winds around and she's
dangling from her hair on these posts
that come out of the back of the ship
and she is literally pain painting the
name of the ship on the back I love it
with her 22 size 22 women's shoe yeah
like sort of the size of Shaquille
O'Neal something like that yeah I
probably can't so not that big then yeah
or bigger
um cool all right so is there so there's
Rapunzel in her hair and her feet is
there anything on the ship that you just
are so proud of love so much and you
have a like a feeling that maybe guests
won't notice it and you want them to
oh that would be so many things oh my
gosh in the imagineering space
um for the kids it's the first
imagineering inspired
um room in the kids space and it's to
give them a peek at what it's like to be
an imagineer and do things so there are
an assortment of things that um
are are there to sort of celebrate some
of our imagineers so if you look you'll
see some of the hard hats and has like
the names of our team on there and then
I didn't know this I didn't know they
were doing there's a um a little thing
that they named for me it's just a a
vial of red paint that's in that space
and I think it says I don't know cable
red or something like that but those
those little little things you actually
have a little less leeway on the ships
because people will walk by a spot like
many times a day so what what kind of
maybe tell me that and what kind of
additional pressure that is yeah I mean
because our guests are living on the
ship they're coming contact with
everything
um more closely right so they can
scrutinize everything so we need to make
sure that the details are there and
they're authentic and they're
maintainable it's sort of all of that to
make sure that that that guest who's
walking past this you know day after day
many times right and there's seeing
everything it has to be it has to be
completed at a really beautiful level of
detail and convincing
so Disney imagineers do you um do you
have any early memories from of National
Geographic of course of course I mean
who
didn't grow with now
magazines
filling their bookcases or in huge
stacks
and the photography was so beautiful and
it really made me want to travel and you
know I mean I grew up as a Navy brat as
we say so I moved like 18 or 19 times
and I loved being I was always in the
U.S but I love being in different parts
of the U.S and
I just love the different cultures and
the people and the food and um so I my
whole adult life for work I have
traveled the globe yeah you had said to
me
um that you kind of see national
government is kind of a natural
absolutely you know National Geographic
makes the real world Fantastical like it
it focuses on just the beauty that you
find in the design of a plant a leaf a
fish I mean it it makes things
extraordinary real life extraordinary
and an engineering we create Fantastical
worlds that we bring to reality so I
think it's a perfect pair it's a yin
yang I love that that's cool
um do you have any advice for we get we
get a lot of people wanting to be not to
explorers photographers filmmakers maybe
a little bit once in a while what what's
your advice for people looking to be an
imagineer well I mean you need to be a
passionate Storyteller first and
foremost and whatever it is you do
whatever your expertise is aerospace
engineering
uh you know I had an engineer tell me
once like they felt they were the most
creative of everybody because they have
to take these crazy insane things we
dream up and make them work so they have
to be phenomenally creative because
they're dealing with realities and they
have to push the limits what's it like
having this blue sky out there idea and
then
sharing that with the folks who do
actually have to I know it's your your
creative overview but then someone
actually has to go and do what Lara says
she wants to do like what is that like
did they say no no way no we're not
going to do that or do they ever push
back and say you're crazy
no no I don't think so I mean there
there may be
constrictions maybe that they make us
aware of but gravity or right laws of
physics I don't think I've ever heard an
imagineer say to another imagineer no
you're crazy you can't do this it's
really more about okay
let's find a way let's see what are the
things that are blocks for us and how
can we overcome it so sometimes a
constraint becomes an opportunity and
you're creative people and you you make
you can make something better out of out
of what whatever that yeah and I think
people who hear ideas and say oh there's
no way you can do this I don't think
they imaginary is the right place for
them you know it's all about how do we
get this done I mean that that's it all
goes back to Walt you know he had this
dream of a theme park in a little Orange
Grove and everybody he talked to was
like you you're crazy you can't get this
done and he found a group of people that
he christened imagineers and they got it
done and look what it's grown into
I think he'd be
a little surprised not totally surprised
by what it's become
[Music]
if you like what you hear and you want
to support more content like this please
rate and review us in your podcast app
and consider a National Geographic
subscription that's the best way to
support overheard go to Nat geo.com
Explore More to subscribe and if you
want to see our documentary and I sure
hope you do we've included a link in the
show notes it features Laura cable along
with many of the other imagineers behind
the project it's called making the wish
Disney's newest cruise ship it'll be on
Disney plus March 3rd and while you're
there check out the docu-series the
imagineering story about other
imagineers all over the world it's all
in your show notes they're right there
in your podcast app
this week's overheard episode is
produced and engineered by senior
producer Brian Gutierrez our other
senior producer is Jacob Pinter our
producer is Kyrie Douglas our senior
editor is Eli Chen Carla Wills is our
manager of audio Devar artalon is our
executive producer of audio our photo
editor is Julie Howe honsdale Sue
composed our theme music this podcast is
a production of National Geographic
Partners Michael Tribble is the vice
president of integrated storytelling
Nathan lump is National Geographics
editor-in-chief and I'm your host Chad
Cohen thanks for listening and see you
next time
foreign
[Music]